Johnston in deep out top NS lanquist back to
Wyatt Johnston toov across to Johnson and a
big save hell and the rebound of the crease Swept
Away by Hutton a real good job spreading out the
offensive zone there's the pass and off the
left arm a hill great BR H will start it out
racing to the red line with Robertson in Pursuit
here's pH right down the middle Amo and put it
off the outside of the net Alex petrangelo has
not skated since he took that puck in the head
late in the San Jose game hin starting in feeds
It Around the Net Robertson a around chance and
Hill holds tight Hill ends up in the net kisar
gains the line drops it off to W he risks it
in deep Michael swats it back to h a he holding
across to colar and off the [Applause] post 30
seconds so it's a carryover power play for the
stars to begin the [Music] second how into the
corner looking to Center to C colar shock a block
think got a pat on that back the other way duchan
racing in Hutton got back to get a piece of them
oh great back check by Ben Hutton and good stick
to poke it away from duchaine now on the wall San
trying to move it back to the line Harley with a
r shot save made Hill in tou take it centered in
it Smith scores Craig Smith second game with the
Stars first goal in a Dallas uniform here's
a look at the play in the corner it's going
to rotate out highs a good shot from the point
just getting this through to the net finds it
way there's Sean and he just wins the battle gets
it across and Craig Smith does a good job getting
his stick down corac can't lift it a little late
on the coverage and Smith opens up the score and
to make a one- nothing Dallas real good play by
Sean putting that puck back out in front and the
golden knights were able to get to Jake ainger
in that series they got pull in game three gave
up six in the clinching game six for the vgk
and tied the most goals he'd allowed in a game
in his career Howen into the offensive end here's
corac with a rot score that hit a body on the way
to the net and Kaden corac is first in the NHL
to tie the game 22y old good little drop pass
first Carlson to howed and then there's the shot
but the screen in the net Carlson makes the first
drop pass he goes to the front of the net that
shot perfectly up top over the right shoulder of
Jake CER duaine rink wide Johnston trying to
get a handle on it never could and hey moves
it for carier charging up byce three on two they
in hurry carier drops it TH or denied by oer Mel
trying to fight through delandria another penalty
delayed call it's going to be a five on three for
the golden knights Hill to the bench hopping
on his W theor AEL one timer sa on and he sto
the rebound from w Maro walking in shot missed
the net tried to go High glove on uttinger now
Mel to Theodore Beat It Down Low Stenson hit
the post on the pass from Stone Michael and
Fox on the face off foxa pulls it to the Corner
Stone gets it though feet fit or they have time
R shot blocked by hackin paa Stevenson T ey by
ainger just before the buzzer to win the period
third period about to begin power play for the
vgk the Twan advantages up redirect from eel
turned away by ainger win the slot battle that
seems to be the trick tonight at both sides of
the ice off this draw score Joe pavelski right
off the faceof Beats Hill and pavelski's first
shot of the night finds the back of the net and
gives Dallas the lead pavelski rolls there's the
shot and it just finds its way to that far
Corner past Aiden Hill and think it caught
the inside of Mark Stone skate you can see how
that kind of dipped just over the left pad and
just like that the Stars grab the 2-1 lead
Joe pavelski H in to Ben he deflects it in
a giving Chase and intercepts Johnston open and
his shot turned away by Hill Hutton up forhead
to Carlson once again Stevenson Stone Carlson up
front here's St just out of his reach been able
to move it to course that shot score it's William
Carlson on the deflection to tie the game with 259
left as Stevenson drives this puck in little
play pass and corac just fires this towards the
there's William Carlson and what a deflection
look at that right up the mid jaap as it goes
past the right shoulder of ainger and William
Carlson both him and corac two points in this
game it's tied it two you mentioned a no surprise
once again Dallas and Vegas in overtime three on
three OT stars in their only game so far this
year went to a shootout to beat St Louis last
Thursday San right in front and Hell kicks it
out just like that San set up by du oh Theodore
I think a turnover just an errant backand right
to the middle first shot for the stars in over
seven minutes hinin into the Zone put it over
the net Theodore got a piece of that the golden
KN three on one the other way Mel Theodore
Stevenson Mel walking into theore and with a
stop Michael the two onone with Theodore patience
patience over and then the right pad saved by AER
oh Theodore Theodore kind of shot Stars won here
in Vegas last year was hint the tie the game 38
seconds left Carlson walking in and AER turned
it away and a big draw against melski trickles
to Hill theodor's going to have to really
hurry here lost the puck very entertaining
overtime save ainger eel tried to wait
him out with him you said eel trying to
wait him out look look look goes down
stays right with him gets that glove
out Jay Theodore 9 for 20 in his career
scores well Theodore we've seen him
the move you're to pick one move he
usually goes to the backand what I like
here switches it up there's the fake and
I think goder you know has tape he's
reading the backand and theer pulls it
back and puts it right upstairs mat Shane
for the Stars scores snapped it quickly to
beid Hill comes in strong side and he sees it
right away goes five right along the ice past
Hill Jonathan Maro up next for the [Music] vgk
trying to give the golden knights the advantage
again in the sh out pulls up and scores snapped
and low [Music] side a little hesitation that
we've seen this shudos guys come in slow he's
going to come in Fast and just kind of stop wait
and perfectly place over that right pad right
below the blocker the golden knights can get a
save here from Aiden Hill on rope hence they'll
win the game cross for it out the golden ice win